foreign
this is Professor mdas science and today
we're going to discuss the energy
eigenvalues of the hydrogen atom in
another one of our videos on rigorous
quantum mechanics the hydrogen atom is
made of a proton bound to an electron
the states of Bank systems are
associated with a spectrum of discrete
or quantized energy eigenvalues in this
video we will start from the
mathematical definition of those energy
eigenvalues which we have derived in one
of the videos that are linked in the
description and we will find out that
energy eigenvalues are actually highly
degenerate we will discuss the
symmetries that give rise to these
degeneracies and we will also introduce
some widely used notation that you've
probably encountered before if you've
studied Atomic physics or chemistry
we're talking about Atomic shells and
sub shells of course and we're also
going to introduce the concept of
spectroscopic notation so let's go
the hydrogen atom is made of a proton
and an electron in the introductory
video on hydrogen we find that the
relevant physics of the system is
encoded by the relative motion of the
proton and the electron and that means
that we can describe the hydrogen atom
with a one particle relative hamiltonian
H which has the usual kinetic energy
tongue and this potential energy term
that's associated with the coulomb
interaction
in the Precision representation we can
rewrite it with the usual kinetic energy
term and the potential energy term which
has the form of a central potential
and for a full derivation you should
check out the introductory video on the
hydrogen atom but as a reminder mu right
here is the reduced mass of the system
and is related to the masses of the
proton and the electron by this equation
P here is the relative momentum given by
this expression in terms of the
individual momentum of the proton and
the electron and R is the relative
position given by the distance between
the proton and the electron
starting with this relative hamiltonian
we can write its eigenvalue equation
like this
where as usual these are the eigenvalues
and Theta viagon functions we have three
quantum numbers labeling the eigenvalues
and eigenfunctions and they are k l and
ml
the label K appears in both eigenvalues
and eigenstates and it can take any
positive integer value
this quantum number is directly
associated with the hamiltonian
eigenvalue equation and labels the
different eigenvalues
the label L also appears in both
eigenvalues and eigenstates and it can
take any non-negative integer value it
is associated with the square orbital
angular momentum and the hydrogen atom
eigenstates are labeled by L because the
operator L squared commutes with the
hamiltonian and this means that we can
choose the energy eigenfunctions to also
be eigenfunctions of L squared
finally the label ml only appears in the
eigenstates and for a given ill it can
be minus L minus L plus one and so on in
steps of one all the way to l
m l is associated with the Z component
of orbital angular momentum and the
hydrogen atom eigenstates are labeled by
ml because the operator LZ commutes with
the hamiltonian and we can choose the
energy eigenfunction to obey this
eigenvalue equation
we've solved this eigenvalue equation at
the top to determine all the bounce
dates of the hydrogen atom in a series
of rather mathematical videos that is
linked in the description
what we want to do today is to take a
closer look at the eigenvalues which
will allow us to expand our
understanding of the hydrogen atom
right so from our earlier videos on
hydrogen we know that the solution of
the eigenvalue equation of the
hamiltonian leads to a discrete energy
Spectrum for the band state of the
hydrogen atom which is given by minus V
ionization energy divided by K plus L
squared
remember also that the ionization energy
EI is given by this expression in terms
of the reduced Mass mu and a number of
fundamental constants and that its
numerical value is 13.6 electron volts
and that's the kind of number that you
probably want to remember
additionally remember that K can only
take positive integer values and that L
can only take non-negative integer
values
looking at the eigenvalue equation at
the top we see that the eigenstates are
labeled by an additional quantum number
ml which does not appear in the
eigenvalues
remembering that for a given L the
possible values of ml are minus L minus
L plus 1 and so on in steps of one all
the way to l
then we can conclude that for every L
there are two L plus one distinct values
of ml
in turn this means that the energy
eigenvalue e k l is at least 2 L plus
one fold degenerate
to put it another way the eigenvalue e k
l has at least a degree of degeneracy
which we will call GL
and which is equal to 2L Plus 1.
this degeneracy is a direct consequence
of rotational invariance the orbital
angular momentum operators commute with
the hamiltonian and therefore angular
momentum is a conserved quantity in the
hydrogen atom
but it turns out that there are even
more degeneracies
note that the eigenvalues ekl don't
separately depend on K and L instead
they depend on the sum K plus l
and this means that if we have a pair of
K and L
and a generally different pair K Prime
and L Prime as long as the sum is the
same then the energy eigenvalues are
also the same
what does that mean that means that
energy eigenvalues can also be
degenerate even if they have different L
labels
just like the 2L plus one degeneracy
associated with ekl arises from
rotational asymmetry this additional
degeneracy that we've just seen when the
sum of kl equals that of K prime plus L
Prime also arises from another symmetry
of the hydrogen atom
this extra symmetry is a little bit more
subtle and I will only say a few words
here classically this symmetry is
present in any potential that arises
from an inverse Square law examples
including Coulomb's law of
electrostatics and Newton's law of
universal gravitation
all these potentials conserve what is
called the Runge lens vector
and in the case of the coulomb law it is
given by a term involving the cross
product of the linear momentum p and the
angular momentum L and the term
involving the Precision Vector r
the extension of this Runge lens Vector
to Quantum Mechanics also leads to a
corresponding conserved quantity and
that in turn leads to this additional
symmetry that we've just found in the
hydrogen atom
so we found that there are plenty of
degeneracies in the energy spectrum of
the hydrogen atom
to put some concrete values to these
degeneracies it will prove convenient to
first introduce a new label we can group
the K and L labels appearing in this sum
and Define a new Collective label n
with this unitation we can write the
eigenvalues as en and set them equal to
minus the ionization energy Over N
squared
given the possible values of K and of L
we can conclude that n which is the sum
of K plus L can only take positive
integer values
and from the definition of n here we can
also conclude that for a given n then L
can take any value from 0 1 2 and so on
in steps of one all the way to n minus
1.
with this new label we can now rewrite
the energy eigenvalue equation of the
hydrogen atom like this
the energy eigenfunctions depend on
three labels n l and ml but the energy
eigenvalues only depend on the label n
so what is the total degeneracy of an
energy are you value en
to answer that question first remember
that for a given ill we have a
degeneracy GL equal to 2L plus one
corresponding to the possible ml values
for the full degeneracy of En we're
going to use GN
as we can see up here for every n l can
run from 0 to n minus 1 which means that
GN is equal to the sum from 0 to n minus
1 of GL
using this expression for GL and
inserting into our expression we can
rewrite GN as equal to this sum of 2L
plus one
this is a standard arithmetic series and
the sum evaluates to N squared
and that's it the energy eigenvalue en
of the hydrogen atom has a degeneracy
equal to N squared
this degeneracy arises from a
combination of rotational symmetry and
also from the conservation of the
quantum mechanical version of the Runge
lens vector
it's important to add a small
clarification to this result
we're working with the non-relativistic
hamiltonian of the hydrogen atom if we
considered electronspin then the
degeneracies we found would actually
double
and if we considered additional
relativistic Corrections then some of
these degeneracies would actually be
lifted but more on that in the videos
Linked In the description
right before we move on we should
introduce some widely used notation that
will be convenient
when working with a hydrogen atom the
quantum numbers that you will encounter
most frequently are n l and ml
these quantum numbers are used so often
that they have special names
n is called the principal quantum number
L is called the azimuthal quantum number
and ml is called the magnetic quantum
number
the name for ML may appear somewhat
arbitrary at this point but its origin
is in the fact that the energy
eigenvalues are degenerate in ml unless
there is a magnetic field
[Music]
in the rest of the video we'll introduce
some additional widely used notation to
describe the hydrogen atom to do so it
will prove convenient to First plot the
edit Dragon values so let's draw a
vertical axis which corresponds to the
energy and we're also going to draw a
horizontal line to set the zero of
energy
as we're discussing bound dates of the
hydrogen atom all energies are negative
and therefore we are going to draw them
below this horizontal line
so let's start with the ground stage n
equals one
the energy is simply minus the
ionization energy which has a value of
remember minus 13.6 electron volts and
remember we'll say that for n equals one
the only possible value for the
asymmetal quantum number is L equals
zero
so how do we plot this in the diagram
we're going to draw this energy
eigenvalue as a short horizontal line at
the corresponding energy
we're now going to label this level with
its printable quantum number n equals
one and also with its asymmetal quantum
number L equals zero
let's make some room
and let's now move on to the first
excited state n equals 2.
the energy is equal to minus the
ionization energy over 4 which has a
numerical value of minus 3.4 electro
volts for n equals 2 we have two
possible values for the asymu for
quantum number L equals zero and one
going to the diagram the energy will be
here
and we're now going to draw this energy
eigenvalue with two horizontal lines
the first is right above the one for the
ground state and we're going to draw
another one to its right here
both correspond to the principal quantum
number n equals two and have the same
value
however we are separating the two
possible as some useful quantum numbers
with the first line here labeled by the
L equals zero down here
and we will add a new label L equals one
for the second line
now both lines correspond to the same
energy we're simply separating them
according to the azimuthal quantum
number for convenience and the reason
why it will become clear a bit later on
let's make some room again
and we will now consider the second
excited state n equals three
the energy is equal to minus the
orientation energy over 9 which has a
numerical value of about minus 1.5
electron volts for n equals three we
have three possible values for the acid
Mutual quantum number and that is L
equals 0 1 and 2.
going to the diagram the energy will be
here but we won't explicitly write it so
that we don't cluster the diagram we're
now going to draw this energy eigenvalue
with three horizontal lines the first is
right above the L equals zero lines for
the ground and first excited States the
second is right above the L equals one
line for the first exercise it stays
and we will draw the third to the right
here
all three lines correspond to the
principal quantum number n equals three
and have the same value
we're again separating them by their
asymuffle quantum numbers with the first
line labeled by the L equals zero down
here the second by L equals one and we
add a new label L equals two for the
third line
and let's make some room again
we now consider the third excited state
n equals four the energy is equal to
minus the ionization energy over 16
which has a numerical value of minor 0.9
EV
for n equals 4 we have four possible
values for the atom U for quantum number
L equals zero one two and three
so going to the diagram the energy will
be here
and we're now going to draw these four
horizontal lines
all lines correspond to the principal
quantum number n equals four and have
the same value we are again separating
them by their asymmetal quantum numbers
labeled by L equals zero L equals one L
equals two and we add the L equals three
label down here
we could of course go on like this
forever and ever and ever for higher
excited States but by now hopefully
you've seen how it works
so let's make some room once more just
for clarity
this depiction of the energy spectrum of
hydrogen is a widely used one that you
may have actually encountered already
while it may appear somewhat strange
that we are explicitly separating the
degenerate eigenvalues according to
their L quantum numbers but saying
nothing about the ml quantum numbers
this depiction allows us to introduce
some important notation that is used in
atomic physics
the first concept that we introduce is
that of an atomic shell and you may have
heard that term before
all states associated with a given
printable quantum number n
form an atomic shell
that means that all energy levels for n
equals 1 form the first shell
all energy levels for n equals 2 form
the second shell and so on
the second concept that we want to
introduce today is that of anatomic
subshell
we divide all states in a given Atomic
shell into subshells and each subshell
is labeled by a given atom euthal
quantum number l
so the N equals one shell has a single
subshell that's right here
the N equals two shell has two subshells
the first corresponds to L equals zero
and the second to L equals one and so on
and while we've introduced these
Concepts in the context of the hydrogen
atom this Norman clay chair is actually
widely used for other atoms too so you
may have encountered it before if you've
studied Atomic physics or chemistry
okay one more exciting thing before we
finish we're going to introduce the
so-called spectroscopic notation
spectroscopy refers to this study of the
electromagnetic radiation that results
from the interaction between light and
matter historically spectroscopy plays a
key role in the development of atomic
physics often preceding formal
understanding of the quantum mechanics
for the hydrogen atom or any other atom
if the system is in an excited state it
can transition to a lower energy state
by the emission of a photon and in
spectroscopy these emitted photons are
detectors and interpreted
I would recommend that you take a look
at our video on the hydrogen spectral
Series where we discuss this in more
detail but for our purposes today all we
need to know is that the spectroscopic
notation we will now introduce has its
origins in the study of photons emitted
by atoms when relaxing from high to low
energy states
before quantum mechanics the various
Atomic spectral lines observed in
spectroscopy experiments were given
names according to their General
features We Now understand these
different features as arising from the
different asymmetal quantum numbers
so the l0 states are described by the
letter S and it comes from the word
sharp to describe the observed spectral
lines
the L equals one states are described by
the letter P and it comes from the word
principle and note actually that this
name has no relation to the printable
quantum number
the L equals two states are described by
the letter d and this label comes from
the word diffuse which again refers to
the features of the spectral lines that
are observed experimentally
the L equals three states are described
by the letter F and the label comes from
the word fundamental
and all subsequent entries are followed
alphabetically so L equals 4 would be g
l equals 5 would be H and so on
fun fact the letter J is actually
omitted because it can be confused with
the letter i but for most applications
you will never really need to go beyond
the F label anyway
we can now go back to our diagram
and re-label it using spectroscopic
notation
the l0 states are the S States and this
means that these are the 1s States these
are the two s States these are the three
s States and these are the four S States
the L equals one states are the P states
there are no one p States and we first
have the two P States then the three p
States the four P States and so on
and the L equals two states are the D
states which start at 3D and in this
diagram we also have 4D
and finally the L equals three states
are the F States and in this diagram we
only have the four if state
many of the ideas that we've introduced
today can be generalized to all other
atoms so if you go on to study Atomic
physics or chemistry you will often find
yourself talking about Atomic shells or
subshells as well as SP or D States so
that's all for today and as always if
you liked the video please subscribe